all I can tell you is I'm being framed I
didn't kill Clifford the phone episode
4:10 the trial of the flash sort of our
take on the classic comic book run the
person standing over Clifford DeVos body
was Barry Allen it's kind of a slam dunk
case for the prosecution I mean there
was the bloody weapon you stand in front
of him he was in his apartment
considering all the evidence they have
against me this trial it's not even
gonna last very long it's not like any
prison can hold you I'm not gonna run I
won't be a fugitive if I'm convicted I
have to go to prison we're not gonna let
that happen for Joe you know as as it
becomes more clear that that Barry's
gonna go to jail he starts to spin out
of control and he does whatever he can
to find some evidence to to free Barry
I'm not gonna let Barry go to prison I
failed his dad I'm not gonna tell him I
need your help my help is in the
stretchy kind as in the underhanded
private investigator kind oh no for the
first time well Joe West cross the line
and do something illegal I'm not taking
a stand
Barry even if that means turning this
case around I'm not going to jail
iris if I testify I have to lie for iris
West you know the man that she loves
it's probably gonna go to jail and
there's only one solution and tell the
truth tell everyone you're the flash it
creates a really interesting dynamic for
the newlyweds this is the only way Barry
I think we've got her attention you
don't say you will not interfere with my
mission interfering is our specialty
[Music]
engaging Jenny's bellowing attack
formation are you fighting
hey everybody flashes back we also got
some new Legion of super-heroes so I'll
explain what's going on because they
teased a couple really big storylines
from both different shows that might be
used for a crossover in a future season
we'll see because it's really big stuff
but because everything's back there's a
new round of the flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and leave a Desir elated
comment on the video so the big deal
with the flash obviously they're just
teasing how crazy everyone is going to
get before they cross the line I've said
it before they're not gonna completely
demonize the team like they demonize
Barry last season but it was really an
alternate version of him so it wasn't
our version of Barry that was doing all
these terrible things but the actress
who plays the thinker's wife was also
teasing on instagram that liked her
scenes with iris are also just as
important to the episode because it's
all about what they're willing to do for
their husbands and a lot of people have
theorized that maybe the thinker's wife
will eventually become the true big bad
of the series because she's almost as
smart as the thinker and she's come up
with all the technology that's enabled
him to survive she created the chair she
created the transfer device that allowed
him to transplant his consciousness into
the new body so it's always possible
that in wanting to save her husband she
just goes completely off the rails and
it's like like that love that drives her
to become the big bad so it's a nice
parallel for irises arc like people
always want her to have a cool storyline
and so it would be nice to see her go
completely off the rails the way that
some characters do during seasons in
order to try and save Barry the way the
team flash kind of went off the rails
trying to save her during season 3 but
of course there's gonna be all kinds of
comic book Easter eggs for that
reverse-flash trial of the flash run and
how that led up into crisis on Infinite
Earths we've gotten teasers for the next
couple of episodes Jay Garrick will be
coming back in a couple episodes too I
believe I've already talked a little bit
about that so I'll link that at the end
of this but something in this clip that
I hadn't thought about in a while is
actually really important for the
episode about
what happened to Barry's father and how
much that weighs on Joe you don't think
about that very often most of the time
when you think about that night you're
thinking about what Barry was feeling
how he wanted to save his mother you're
not really thinking about Joe West
because if Yuri watched the pilot
episode he is adamant that Barry is
wrong there was not another man in
yellow that night
of course you don't believe me you never
believe me okay you want to do this now
out here fine Mardon is dead there is no
controlling the weather Barry just like
there was no lightning storm in your
house that night it was your brain
helping a scared little boy accept what
he saw my dad did not yes he did your
dad killed your mother Barry I am sorry
son I'm not gonna let Barry go to prison
I failed his dad I'm not gonna fail him
I need your help so just imagine how
shitty Joe felt after all of Barry's
conspiracy theories for those past 10
years have been proven right but moving
into Legion of super-heroes territory we
finally have a legit Legion in the air
Oberst now this is the Legion of
supergirls universe of Earth 38 so it'll
be interesting to see if we just stick
with these characters because there are
earth 1 versions of the characters like
they've teased that there is an earth 1
Supergirl there is an earth 1 Superman
but they're off somewhere else or they
haven't left Krypton yet just something
else is going on with them the writers
haven't revealed it in case they want to
change their mind or do some interesting
story down the road they don't want to
pin themselves into a corner but they
finally revealed why they came back to
present day so the ones that we met so
far are not the entire Legion there's
obviously more characters they tease
lightning less but they said that they
came back in time because a mysterious
extinction-level event happens in the
24th or 25th century it serves as like
this reboot for the human race like it
wipes all their culture all their
history away they have to rebuild so
everything they know about Earth from
present day comes from Mon el telling
them stories like there's that funny bon
jovi audio in that clip that's because
he brought Bon Jovi to the Future which
you either think is a terrible thing to
do or a really funny thing depending on
what you think of the characters thus
far this version of Brainiac 5 seems
like he's totally nice he doesn't seem
like he's going to go off the rails
anytime soon they sort
didn't ease that but obviously they're
gonna be in the next couple of episodes
so it'll be interesting to see what they
tease but the extinction level event
that they're trying to stop was caused
by the blight which is this race from DC
Comics they're sort of like the
Xenomorphs but they don't know quite how
to stop them they just know that they
have to chill out till the 24th century
and survive with the information
necessary to stop them so this like
what's happening in present day has
absolutely nothing to do with their
mission they accidentally got knocked
out of hypersleep that's why they're
helping Supergirl out so presumably at
the end of their arc they'll go back
into hypersleep they'll wake up in the
25th century and defeat the blight and
that'll be the end of it so that's all
we really know them obviously them
teasing lightning last means like there
might be other Legion characters they
bring on the show but just mentioning
her doesn't confirm that she's coming on
like I haven't heard anything from the
producers or the writers or anything
like that so just let me know in the
comments what do you think of the Legion
of super-heroes so far you know that
they're big characters in the arrowverse
how do you want them to be used in
future seasons like do you want them to
get involved with one of the big
crossover episodes because a legion of
super-heroes TV show feels like an
upgraded version of legends of tomorrow
and i don't feel like they're gonna
cancel that show anytime soon so it's
kind of weird you have a weird situation
where you have these really cool
characters but I feel like as long as
the legends of tomorrow is on the air
they're not gonna do a legion TV show
but they could bring some of these
characters back I don't know what the
rules are for using Brainiac 5 because
Brainiac feels like a movie character
he'll probably show up in one of the Man
of Steel movies eventually but don't
worry about that now we'll probably get
some more information at Comic Con
usually that's when people get to ask
questions like that like hey yes I'm
really awesome characters when are they
coming back but like I said there's a
new round of the flash ring giveaway
I'll announce the winner from this video
when I post my episode video tonight
congratulations to the winner from my
last video Cody hall please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here to learn about the
upcoming episodes of the flash and click
here for the Deadpool Family Guy episode
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight